[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about
sparsity and compression and compress
sensing and now I'm going to tell you
kind of what I mean mathematically by
sparsity all right this is gonna be kind
of fun so the the big idea here with
sparsity is that you have some vector of
data X this is probably a really high
dimensional measurement of some system
you care about this could be the million
pixels of your image rearranged into a
million by one tall skinny vector and
the idea is that if I take this high
dimensional signal in in kind of the
natural measurement space there is some
transformed basis some big sigh basis
maybe this is the DFT matrix the
discrete Fourier transform matrix in
which case I can represent my original
data in terms of the Fourier
coefficients this tall vector s that has
exactly the same number of elements if
this has a million elements then s has a
million elements but the key observation
here is that s is s is sparse which
means that it has mostly zero entries
and so only a small number of these s
terms are nonzero there's only a few
nonzero entries of s in this Fourier
transformed domain okay and this is this
this basis side doesn't have to be a
Fourier transform it could be a wavelet
transform it can be some other
transformation that you cook up or
someone else cooks up where you can
efficiently represent your data okay so
this is the idea of sparsity and
compression is that we take our signal X
we represent it as a vector in some
other basis and in that other basis if
we're careful then that vector s that
representation will be sparse meaning
mostly zeros and that allows us to store
a lot less information than our million
pixels we only have to store these kind
of nonzero coefficients and that
requires if we want to use this for a
compression it basically is like a
decoder ring this requires all of us to
agree that we are going
to compress in this basis okay so if I
use JPEG compression we're all agreeing
to use the fast Fourier transform basis
and that means that if I tell you that I
need coefficients five seventeen and
thirty nine we all know what modes what
kind of columns of psy those correspond
to okay so you all have to agree ahead
of time what basis you're using for
compression JPEG uses the the DFT basis
or the fast Fourier transform basis JPEG
2000 uses wavelet basis and you have to
tell in when you save your file you have
to say what wavelet basis you're using
are using koi Flitz or you know horror
transform wavelets or you have to decide
and tell the person you're sending that
picture - what's the decoder ring what's
the basis that they need to go back to
real space okay so that's the idea of
sparsity is that you can write your your
signal X and some new basis and it
mostly contains zero and I'm just going
to write that over here because we're
going to use this later we're gonna say
X our original signal equals sy times s
where again where s is sparse and we're
gonna call sy a universal basis so I'm
gonna I'm gonna kind of write this down
for you this is what I mean I'm gonna
call this a universal basis and what I
mean by a universal basis this is an N
by n humongous square matrix okay that
square matrix let's say these are
megapixel images this is a million by
million basis and to some extent we this
basis being universal gives us the
flexibility of representing any natural
image sparsely so this doesn't have to
this could be an image of a face this
could be an image of you know a remote
control it could be an image of a dog a
cat a coffee cup you name it it can be
represented in this Fourier basis and
chances are if it's a natural image it
happens to be sparse in that Fourier
basis okay now you can also have a
tailored basis and we're going to talk
about this also in fact we already have
talked about this a tailored
basis that could be for example from the
SVD remember the singular value
decomposition from Chapter one there's a
whole lecture series on the SVD where
instead of having X be some generic
signal like a dog a cat a coffee cup a
human face if we know that what we're
getting is an image of a human face we
absolutely know that X is a human face I
don't need all of these degrees of
freedom that could possibly encode
coffee cups and mountains and other
things if I know that X is a human face
then what I can do is I can build a big
library of human faces and this big
matrix X so each column will be you know
a different human face maybe I have
thousands maybe this is the face book
library and I have millions of examples
of human faces and then what I do is I
run the SVD and I get a reduced basis
you are times Sigma R times V R
transpose where now this you are is a
library a basis that I can use to
represent human faces this is what we
call a tailored basis so up here the
Fourier transform is a universal basis
we can encode anything but we could also
use a tailored basis like the SVD okay
and if we use the SVD we would have the
exact same kind of picture on the left
we would take our high dimensional
signal X but now it's the product of a
tall skinny matrix this you are this is
size n by r this is size n by n this
will only need our columns maybe a
hundred maybe a thousand columns instead
of a million because I'm not trying to
encode anything I'm just trying to
encode human faces and so in this
representation
I can still compress X I can still write
x in terms of many many fewer numbers in
this a vector but this a is not sparse
anymore a is just a few numbers it's our
numbers that tell me what combination of
this library I need to add up to get X
okay so I can compress my signal in a
universal basis I can compress my signal
in a tailored basis but only this s
vector in my universal basis is going to
be sparse okay so sparsity
usually what I'm referring to is when
you take a high dimensional signal and
you represent it in some kind of a
uniform a universal basis like Fourier
transform or wavelets then it's
representation becomes very very sparse
okay
and we're going to use this property in
in the next lectures too for example can
we identify if I only measured a small
subset of X maybe I only measured 10% of
the values in X can I infer what these
nonzero fourier coefficients are that's
the compressed sensing problem and again
this was not possible 20-25 years ago
but with advances in optimization and
sparse sparsity promoting optimization
we can now find those sparse Fourier
coefficients and therefore we construct
the full image even if we massively
subsample the pixels this is a this is
kind of almost like harry potter level
magic you know even compression is kind
of Harry Potter magic you take a million
pixels you throw away 95% of them and
somehow I claim that you can you can
still reconstruct the image even with
only 5% of the Fourier coefficients but
what's even more impressive is if you
didn't even measure those million pixels
to begin with so if I only measure a
subset of those pixels can I infer what
entries are nonzero so that's all coming
up that's called compressed sensing it's
super interesting really really rich
mathematical theory and that's what I'm
going to show you next
all right thank you